hey guys how's it goin welcome back the
cooking was Justine I'm Justine and
today we're gonna be baking something
really special
last week was James Gunn's birthday and
I was joking with him on Twitter about
making a group cake for his birthday and
then I thought why don't I actually try
to make one and see what happens so
let's get started
let's get all of our stuff together here
so you're new here we bake everything in
the blender so that's what we're doing
hmm smells nice
1 in 1/4 cups water what about the eggs
let's do the eggs first one egg two egg
three eggs 1/4 cups water when we go 1/2
cup of vegetable oil okay
I've cops like a railing right there
fantastic and now we blend look
we're looking in a blender you must take
into consideration that you're not
supposed to be using a plunger so two
things might not go as planned
at 14 to 19 minutes for this delicious
mixture into the pan as you do this
looks like chocolate milk if this
doesn't work I'm going to be so upset a
little bit in here this is really a thin
cake this is gonna be fantastic this is
not a very thick a it doesn't even cover
the bottom of the pan it's probably
gonna bake for two minutes
why did you decide well something's
happened okay and you go with your
friend what's gonna happen okay uh good
luck it's not time to attempt to
decorate the cake I looked up a few
reference images of grouped and this is
the one that I'm going to be using so
let's see how closely I can get this
cake to look like root shall we well you
look good I don't know this is gonna
work I kind of want this side because
this looks like a face a bird face okay
oh it's so toasty it's so warm so here
we go um okay I don't know what I'm
doing let's try to make the group face
first like a nice shape so I'm probably
going to use this again I'm not sure
maybe the find jawline for you sir
how's it taste Thanks edible currently
cutting out some Groot eyes see he's got
a little bit of like a bump here on his
nose so I'm gonna just replace that with
this eyeball that I cut out truthfully I
don't what the hell I'm doing
I don't know I'm doing I'm doing I'll
just stick this I guess in my mouth so
this is where we are so far it looks
absolutely terrifying but that's okay
I'm uh clearly doing my best now time to
put on some icing to hopefully just sort
of mold this all together this is not
going well let's just put this on here
are you grew during my growth are we
both grew oh no this is cake dunya this
is an injector yeah it's great it makes
sense from this angle look at his face
wait really well I heard some things in
here I was expecting a lot worse all
right groots looking pretty good but we
need to put some branches on him just to
make him feel at home
so with his here grow you are in your
ear in your home territory I'll just
stick this I guess right here
there we go that's nice and that my
friends is my really sad attempt at a
group cake happy belated birthday James
hope you guys enjoyed this video I'll
see you guys in the next one leave me
some comments below and let me know what
you would like me to cook next don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
for more videos that's all I've got for
you today thankfully do you want some
Jen alright now just take a little bite
the tree edible
I washed the tree before I put it on the
cake though okay see you guys later
peace out I'm indifferent about the
chips